what are some other cool robots in the
early days that stand out to you I mean
there's a million we can go through but
like what um maybe what what was like a
challenging one like a really
challenging one in the early days
I mean I remember the breakfast robot
which was my second project was a
challenging one so eating cereal yeah
it's a robot that like pours milk and
cereal and feeds me with a spoon I was
mostly challenging because it was so
like
everything had to be in the right
location and there were so many takes
before I got everything right and by
right I mean it makes an absolute mess
um yeah that one was challenging What It
Takes was that one
I don't know probably 12 10. everywhere
as a mess and also I use like Cheerios
for the cereals and my it's shot in my
old bedroom in San Francisco and the
floors were sticky for weeks afterwards
Jesus goes into your autobiography yeah
because you have like a couple of
feeding ones right the soup isn't that a
soup one yeah there's a Super Robot
um there's a beer pouring robot
I mean that's that's awesome that's a
difficult robotics problem
in the shitty and the in the perfect
version
of having an arm that interacts
intimately with a human being and one of
the most intimate things you can do with
a human being that's PG is defeated
where's he going with this uh oh my God
he's a YouTube comic come live and they
got like damn it so like to me there's a
like feeding is tricky
or even like getting a beer even pouring
a beer is tough into a glass yeah it's
trickier than anyone who hasn't tried it
thanks and
even making it I think what I realized
is that like
making things really shitty or like
failing in a spectacular way is also its
own sort of skill because like the
shittiest robot is the one that doesn't
turn on right but like that isn't much
to watch so it was always like wanting
for it to fail in these kind of
spectacular ways
um no there's a lot of stuff to be said
about Engineering in it